so without further ado let's get started
[Music]
[ __ ] steam wow [ __ ] bye hello bye
okay let's guess that's how I scream
then find all four rubber rings
[Music]
oh hi I'm fine my name is Marco okay all
right hi hello my name is markiplier I'm
I make videos on the internet
oh god a nail I don't know why I have a
nail but I got I got a nail oh do I need
a nail to be able to hang this thing up
there okay I'm taking a picture
oh hi joy joy joy joy you're why monoi I
know what your timing no means
oh why I don't like this I don't want to
play with your tiny man bonbon all right
I guess this is normal
ah yes I love this if I know my thing
about cars more than one of you that's a
new predicament that I have to deal with
and I can't sprint very far because I'm
out of shape I eat too many donuts all
right I think the trick is I just got to
move quickly find whatever the hell me
I'm big smart in my brain hole I'm
braced I'm so I got it
oh this looks hi how are you doing okay
well I will pretend like that didn't
happen we know about your problem is it
mannequins or is it all the poop in my
pants we got away from it oh my god I
know
I see you moving there
yeah that's some pretty dramatic music
you don't need to be playing that I'm
looking for I don't even know what it
looks like I don't even know what it
smells like
hi sorry I'm sorry
it looked like I was that like crotch
height they're not my intention
didn't mean to go face-first into your
crotch panic panic I'm panicking
should I panic it's panic you're gonna
close the dough can't hide from me I
know when I'm about okay Brantley I'm in
there's all now I must be very small
nobody make a joke about the rules and I
hit the ground running done magnetized
not all therefore I'm gonna throw you
out of wall I'm sorry hello how are you
doing welcome to that chicken looks
oddly promiscuous don't wanna say
nothing about that chicken by DA I can't
lift that door with my butthole
there's no way see ya
happen
[Music]